вти та науки Дмитро Табачник під час
робочого візиту на харківщину
рецеміністр відвідав книжкову фабрику
Глобус тут друкується частина
підручників для українських школярів о
дер замовлені цього року підручники для
першого та 11-го класів за словами
Дмитра тобачника відтепер мову
підручників можна обирати і це
стосується не тільки російської чи
української а й мов національних меншин
зокрема молдавської угорської румунської
та польської я считаю что школы должны
заказывать учебники так как у них
происходит процесс обучения это не
Политика это абсолютно просто нормальное
уважительное отношение к людям у вас
словацкая школа украинская школа со
словацким языком преподавания пожалуйста
загалом держзамовлення склало 6,5 мльнів
примірників з них 2, по мовами
національних меншин словами міністра
освіти Дмитра Табачника держзамовлення
виконано у призначений термін
государственный заказ выполнен по
Первому классу полністю до 15 августа по
11-му классу до 20 августа и не просто
выполнен а доставлены учебники
изготовленные за деньги государственного
заказа во все регионы України і
практически на 100% розвезены уже по
школам За підрахунками Дмитра Табачника
цьогорічна вартість підручника складає
12 грн 80
копі